France started their own Saturday Night
Live yeah and you hosted the first
episode yeah okay I was the first host
now what is different about the French
Senate live it was working one it was
aired on a Thursday is that true
it's true I swear because we don't want
to do you know exactly like you guys do
we wanted this little difference right
now the French toss right right the
French want to make it a little bit
they're out of it yeah but it was great
I'm a big fan of the show that the
original show and I was really honored
and re happy to host the first one in
France it was great a great experience
what fascinated me I didn't know this is
that on the French turnout live they do
the sketches that have some of the
classic sketches that have been done on
the original Sarah not one yeah what
yeah well you you did you did one that's
a that's one of the great classics of
all time estar not long exactly and you
guys reproduced it exactly but I mean we
stole it that's the word you stole it
yeah I stole it and which one did you do
cowbell you did cowbell and you're
you're the one you're the guy I'm damned
I'm the Cobell er you're the cowbell er
that's hatchet obits Kabbalistic obelisk
that's too smart for me let's take a
look at this French version of cowbell
Jews awesome concept album
Oh Jeff
[Music]
it's even cold Saturday night
yeah I'm first get no it's on Thursdays
that's fantastic
I'm thinking of maybe doing remake of
other shows I don't know maybe Good
Morning America as a late-night it's a
late night show
you